il saura matelas et en fait j'ai dormi
par terre pendant pendant six mois c'est
la surpopulation et deux dans la cellule
ouais ouais deux dents à ses yeux ça se
passait bien avec votre co détenus bah
oui voila quoi se dire mais qu'il en
voit passer un ca change tout le temps
c'est permanent mais bon voilà faut
s'adapter
faux on discute un peu pourquoi tu es là
en fait la première question c'est
pourquoi tu es là bien sûr donc parce
que bon les cette histoire ça se passe
toujours mal ou pas pourquoi lui vaut
deux codétenus mois pour un vol pour un
vol vous voulu raconter l'histoire
ouais ouais la hume annonce la couleur
mathieu là tu es parti pour des années
donc là vous avez 18 ans vous dit vous
êtes est parti pour des années on en 84
ouais mais ce qui va se passer c'est
quand 85 alors que vous êtes en prison
vous allez apprendre une terrible
nouvelle ce qu'on vous apprend que vous
êtes séropositif
ouais parce que en fait les tests pour
le virus du sida date de 85 et donc ils
décident dans les prisons de faire de
tester tout le monde et c'est donc bah
je fais un test est comme ma copine
c'était une toxicomane en fait à
l'extérieur
vous le saviez pas ça non je ne savais
pas alors qu'elle habitait avec vous ne
saviez pas du tout c'est fou ah si je
savais qu'elle était toxicomane à bord
n'a vait pas qu'elle était touchée par
le virus d'accord elle vous l'a jamais
elle ne pouvait pas le savoir toute
façon et les tests soient arrivés dans
85 d'accord donc finalement en 85 je
décide de faire un test
et boum j'apprends que je suis
séropositif
à quoi donc donc crise alors 19 ans en
prison
séropositif qui souvent fait en fait je
passe mon anniversaire et j'apprends que
je pars pour des années qui en plus qui
à l'époque la maladie c'était comme le
commise aujourd'hui s'est on passait à
la trappe
c'était pire c'est pire des pires c'est
pire c'était vraiment si c'était chaud
donc à laisser terminer n'y a plus
d'espoir quoi alors finalement les
première trithérapie vous sauve de
justesse alors ça c'est dans les années
90 ouais mais là donc pendant les cinq
années
vous êtes n'est pas de traitement
pendant dix ans
maintenant disant d'accord eux pendant
dix ans sans traitement il n'existait
pas femmes ont des traitements mais les
vrais traitement soirée mais en 96 donc
donc mais entre temps j'ai dû faire mes
années je me suis mis en cavale dans les
années 90 justement parce que vous vous
n'avez qu'une idée en tête si vous c'est
vous et vale à partir du moment où on a
plus d'avenir où on n'a plus rien à
perdre c'est terminé moi je veux dire
j'ai ma vie je vais pas la passer en
prison
je fais tout pour pouvoir sortir donc
tentative d'évasion où c'était donc je
mets un jour on me donne une perte parce
que j'arrive à la fin des dix ans en
fait vous allez passer quatre ans à
fleury voilà je passe quatre ans à
fleury après je viens en centre de
détention
bon ou c'est plus cool il me donne des
permissions parce que j'arrive en fait à
pouvoir a plus qu'à me peine à pouvoir
être dans des conditions pour savoir
sortir donkey kong admission voilà
exactement mais bon il n'y a pas de
perspective moi je me mets en cavale on
me donne 10 jours sans oublier les
adresses de la prison 1
voilà je suis parti je suis parti
j'avais à l'époque j'avais 24 ans